can we monogram
put our names on all right i'm down with
that all right 68 degrees our high for
the day today mostly
clear skies but the most important part
is this number look at this this is 10
above average we told you
it'd feel more like march by the time we
got to today and
there you go denver though still feels
like winter 35 degrees their high in
mile high
with partly sunny skies let's get to
some neighborhoods shall we this time we
start off
in the northwest part of the valley
cincinnati hills 65 for you sky canyon
included summerlin you're at 60 to the
north we go aleante at 62 downtown and
north las vegas coming in at 64. 63 on
the east side
70 still for you whitney ranch and green
valley
we're at 64 henderson roads ranch
mountain's edge both in the low 60's and
seven hills right now at 63 degrees
currently 71 for prep nice mild boulder
city 61.
milder in laughlin and of course death
valley 69 degrees for you
68 currently for sandy valley so this
big ridge still up and over here in the
bc keeping us nice and mild here
deflecting any type of precip or storms
from the pacific northwest after they
have
had so much rainfall one thing we are
eyeing are the winds and we have a daily
look at your winds breezy saturday
signifying that change from milder
temperatures to cooler temperatures
and then next week a much stronger
system rolls in and look at that
your gusts really pick up on tuesday
this is when we could see a wind
advisory
issued by the national weather service
and if it does you know we'll be all
over it
44 degrees overnight mostly clear skies
chilly conditions winds stay light
tonight
winds stay light for tomorrow too your
high
still at 68 degrees mild conditions and
above average still 10 degrees above
normal in fact many neighborhoods for
tomorrow in the high 60s
some of you will touch in the 70s the
east side sunrise manor
green valley and possibly nellis for
tomorrow afternoon
meanwhile 65 for pump tomorrow double
sixes for boulder city laflin you're for
sure will be in the mid 70's
tomorrow later on a day here's your
extended forecast now breezy saturday
like we talked about cooler by sunday
mlk day looking good but we'll kick up
those winds
gusty winds on tuesday and cooler
temperatures it's fun while lasting
right
high 50's by hump day next week that is
your most accurate forecast brian love
the tie buddy